And that wasn't the first fucking thing you told me.
Not going over there.
That slippery twink is going to remember who owns him.
I'm gonna fuck everyone in that rancid shithole,
I swear to god.
You under control here?
Of course I do.
Fuck you! Now shoo!
Take care of the piss, baby.
Oh! Unacceptable.
You're fired.
What is this?
Wrist ruffles.
Is this 1750?
Burn it like the witches who wore it. He knows.
But he tore up my best model.
And you know the show.
Can't wait for that unlucky bitch
to pull herself back together.
Melissa, get over here!
Finally, Kitty,
another drink.
Can you believe what that piece of shit did?
The ungrateful whore.
No, he didn't fucking quit.
It's worse. He moved.